apologies from councillor sure cancel
Rotom councillor eaves
councillor Cooper and kept the sparing
and substitute members we may have
councillor Cornel West and welcome Carol
thank you standing in councillors
bearing number members attending minutes
of the meeting held on the 24th of
booyah item 5 to receive declarations of
interest on item safety annual dit
letter and to consider the report of the
section 151 officer drawing members
attention to the annual audit mentor for
2017-18 sorry I've been stuck in the
high street 15 minutes what I've set
this stage is Chris to it the external
auditor has been stuck in traffic so go
back to item 6
so I wasn't planning to going to D so in
terms of the findings of that report so
to say that C we were given a an
unqualified but it helped with our
financial statements the year-end and
there's no other substantial matters to
report in terms of their findings so the
other purpose of the an audit lecture is
to agree the final feed the audit so the
e report sets out both the original
belfie that was agreed for the core
audit work which was 47,000 prior to the
commencement of the audit the episode or
should have prepared a plan of their
work and and that as they did that they
identify some additional areas were
asian upon the call work that they do
every year so there was already some
addition fee associated with that which
we were expecting and during the audit
they also found some other areas of
testing work that they needed to do so
the final thing that they've arrived at
is sixty four thousand one hundred and
fifty four thousand pounds which is
obviously an increase above the scale
the original scale fee that was left out
and so in terms of that we've obviously
been through with the auditors to make
sure that we're happy that all the work
that they carry
we agree was necessary and proportionate
and the beings also been very public
secretary appointments and committee to
make sure that they're happy with the
engineer is robust as well so we have
accepted that that then left me and it's
just to note as well that their Housing
Benefit and substitute is still ongoing
so there will be some additional and the
associated with that work as well and
the selling for that is currently
estimated to eight thousand one hundred
eighty four pounds but we are expecting
there will be some level of additional
fee association for that as well that
will be presented back to the next
budget committee approval so the
recommendation of the report is just to
note the annual audit of Zion and the
scale fee the eight thousand pounds and
we have been budgeted for them yes
that's correct
so what the discography is the level
that were you expected in in the budget
so anything open above that will be an
additional pressure on the budget this
year but we can we can absorb other than
our budget thank you um in suspend Thank
You gentleman
there seems to be some a bit of a gray
area around the distance rate some feel
evaluations it doesn't seem so the
themes with some difficulty moving on
between sorry 6:15
considering it affects every single
council in the country but the
arrangement seems a bit grave it seems
to be a problem moving information
around between the valuation office and
the council yes I am so there's a couple
of things in terms of them you know what
the auditors have pointed out in terms
of the appeals of division and so one we
changed our methodology in terms of how
we calculate that appeals to provision
but the auditors were happy with the
approach that we took this year but
secondly as we say there's a sort of
ongoing issue in terms of the valuation
office it's it's not being difficult
shouldn't necessarily get up-to-date
information in terms of where appeals
are out from the valuation office and
that's an issue that many other councils
are experiencing as well and it's partly
the reason they've redesigned the
process and introduced the new check the
challenge appeal process but that is
still ongoing and we're not necessarily
seeing all of the outputs of that coming
through quickly at the moment so if he
was an ongoing issue in terms of the
timeliness and you have to see of the
information we get to the valuation
offices but that has been raised with
them and I think as you say a number of
counts on the race relations as well so
but they're both emotional approach to
the problem yes yes yes thank you
boy you think you just need to confirm
that I'm understanding the Dean fees
correctly the the final fear by shoes
2016 decree also because too
finally on page 623 - for 2016-17 the
spirit of fire 526 they they included
additional work Jim it's not just the
yeah is also additionally Scalf a and
then what was the additional work last
unit it was important or it can we see
at the morally to get ripoff was how
we've got an additional fee of 69
thousand pounds I just wondered what it
was lost here how much I can carry on
where the yeah I've got filmmakers
probably about half of that I'm not sure
I don't think you've sent their monk me
as I don't come for the actual finger
velocities a hand what we have reported
that previously to what it committee so
adjuster yeah but so always wanna keep
track of the different reason that was
important how can we help ourselves okay
so we quite happy to I buried that note
part of the overall work that the as
part of the year-end accounts they are
CSS our value for money is leaking in as
well and as part of that work they
identified some recommendations which
they thought we should address and
internal audits then obviously wanted to
our progress against those
recommendations during equals here and
what we've done is that our response to
some of those recommendations and yeah
help us against those so yeah the
appendix to the report sets out a wise
recommendations our management's
response and them and the G date and
where we are with those so something
like is related to the employment
process and our budget monitoring and
process that we put in place measures to
make sure they're addressed through our
regular budget monitoring and budget
certainly supports they specifically
asked us to pits and more sensitivity
analysis when we set the budget around
at the achievement of our savings and
some black writing status which we've
agreed to do they further identified and
some areas in terms of our performance
framework literature also agreed to
address and that was reported as partly
to report which went to a deputy
take back the third area where they
identified some recommendations within
terms of the work we were doing on our
green gateway trading company they
wanted to ensure that we've got a robust
governance profound evidence base for
any further work we've we do in this
area and as part of the estate plans we
are currently pressing to investment
board again we're thinking to make sure
that with all those recommendations are
addressed going forward
so in terms of page 746 firstly the AG
arrangements for sanctuary housing and
it was a mistake arrangement with
secretary housing in terms the vit that
was payable I think as we reported at
the Audit Committee in July we haven't
got the full audit trail papers relating
to that and we have done some further
investigation since then to see if we
can establish those papers unfortunately
we're still not able to halt audit trail
of all those papers but I think the risk
level is low given that some trees or
firm accounts have separately being
audited and that they're satisfied with
the arrangements are in place and Henson
young said that they would not be
looking for that sketchy area very
beautiful so I think they're happening
for this
that lie now that we've done all the
work that we can to establish the final
one is about fun what about the
adventures and the issue that identified
the relationship that was purely due to
timing issue and we've agreed that we
will make sure that the reports are
running the actual year end date to
avoid any issues in terms of exercising
those two Ledger's at year-end so that
should not be an issue and the final one
is about the level of controls and
internal audit and I recommended that in
the IT audit - 3 1919 and we have again
made plans to address that during this
financial yeah and that will be reported
as part of the later on internal audit
brightness as well that was the main the
due dates I know in the past a lot of
the dates that we set with slip family
blaming the substantial problems can we
be fairly certain that these dates will
be next year
yes so what of the recommendations that
haven't yet been fully implemented I
think we have reasonable that degree of
confidence that the deliverable dates
are achievable
we're like to change we would obviously
never report our backs and committee a
later date that I've got no reason to
think that these are not different
17.6 vit right
thank you housing it's got three five
two nine two sorry three five one nine
so yeah are we getting that money back
from secretary oh yeah have you got a
date one that will be paid yes I respond
we have so that was purely a timing
issue over um we've got the money is now
so even we have received that that
amount of money so it's more about you
just establishing what the original and
sort of agreement was but we've got the
in terms of the equity of the money safe
they received a thank you just me to an
Oscar met some 17.3 beyond seven point
four segments of a workbook and we've
spent locally protein trading companies
about some pardons for project
management of complex capital projects
so this might be prior to going into
Greek bring Gateway trading development
they cook that they could be able to buy
the investment board for instance
presumably I just want to know whether
the our auditors was satisfied with the
response that as we do not undertake
sufficient volume of complex government
projects we don't need to put in place
specific RDC guidance just because we
don't do sufficient on a bit concerned
that you know we could potentially be
doing quite large and they would still
be quite complex at some degree and
certainly complex but asked as a small
council and I just went to summer shorts
read that from the air reporters that
Craig book that no that's sufficient
if some audio haven't will be sort of
looking at the areas of concern or you
know the urban design majors part of
this year's audit so if there were there
any concerns and they would be phrasing
that through the 1819 orders boxes
Indian audit so though you know that
just to be clear Ernst and Young
I'm not bothered by our management
response at this point in time they'll
be bothered next year it's not it's not
that they're not bothered and they are
already doing their sort of early
engagement with us and planning out
their the work that they will need to do
is for 1819 they haven't specifically we
sort of tested their value for money
opinion obviously for 1819 year and they
would be really looking at their spots
as a part of the work we did for the
closure of 1718 accounts that we
obviously had discussions with them
about the work that was ongoing to
address the recommendations that they
had put forward and they were satisfied
that we were getting adequate plans in
place they haven't specifically seen our
particular response as part of this
report yet because this is an internal
internal audit driven so we're so they
are they have given a recommendation and
that we have and they haven't read the
response on this this bit of paper to
their recommendation that's partly the
nature of external do work they do not
sort of do continuous monitoring during
the year it's obviously focused around
you and so we had discussions with them
in terms of the 1719 accounts and they
were happy that we were putting in place
actions to it
their recommendations essentially
they've revisit the process next year so
they're looking for us to make some
progress in this area we want to thank
don't worry project manager bought us
and says actually how we manage projects
so that's the review we come to
undertake this year and provide guidance
which will be finished in three days
time yesterday so 2019 I was looking at
specifically at the paragraph which has
next week we have a big table a two or
three paragraphs one isn't easy work we
just so the date will be when roughly
but a report which says November 2018
for these there was four that in
relation to do it sebacic work that
we're doing at the moment and the
investment board report so we're saying
that the work we've done we that is
compliant at this point in time in
November 2018 in terms of their
recommendations so we've had any
conversations already with this year
about this year's order and they're
aware that we the work we're doing on
the asset program behind the fact that
we follow in the Treasury so I don't
have a bunch of these children five case
model so that they're aware that we're
using an established guidelines set of
procedures to receive that work but
obviously they haven't formed an actual
opinion at the stage because that will
happen as part of 1919 thank you so they
are aware of the responsive
feeling they are waiting on this report
okay thank you you happy with that
yeah yeah so the recommendation is that
the extolling leaders recommendations be
noted two degrees
like this is my second progress report
for the 2018-19 compromise members of
enough faith and complete audio
engagements
did you really be able to plan for 1819
one of the things about the bridges it's
the straightaways resource implications
for into an audience when we set the
early found back in March it's based on
a presumption that we would have two
members of staff in post this is not
happening essentially we live up to
recruit a member of staff and his hope
that they would be imposed by April
I've been running difficulties with a
recruitment campaign we've actually have
been recruited go out twice to fill the
vacant post I can I can report that we
have successfully and they were
appointed an individual to the vacant
post and Becky West is sitting alongside
myself today
so we've filled the vacant post but this
didn't actually happen until September
so we're playing a catch-up game and
that actually if you already plan we set
the commencement year might be delivered
in full because we're not have the
resources in place to deliver the audit
plan that said the audit plan itself is
prioritized so there are those key
audits were to prioritize is one of the
Prada one which we have to deliver to
mainly me to provide an opinion at year
end and this feeds into the government's
and your company statement so we are now
looking at completing almost priority
one orders this is our main focus now so
as I said we've been playing catch-up
since its September so with our main
focus is now those priority one audits
that I came for me to deliver opinion
and year-end and hopefully we may still
have some resources left over Billy for
some of the upper bodies that were set
help me with it yourself so if I can
direct members 28.5
and appendix one this actually sets out
in work we've completed a date a citizen
of the committee meeting in July but
completed another two areas free
cleaning contract provided an adequate
short ranking we've also done an audit
of creditors and provided a good
assurance opinion
we'll also undertaken some light touch
application to what it would have
actually looked at the user access
permissions and also where the
parameters the system was set up
correctly at the start of the year so
that's the audience we have a complete
today so I'd like to uh now talk about
capital productivity much of the work
that CalPERS probably on the tanker and
by the compliance team face and read
some vendor revolves around the output
from the National forward initiative
exercise a national initiative exercises
where we supply the National woody
opposite authors with a number of data
sets know what they doing is matched all
these data sets and then report back to
us the results and this basically
indicates possible fraud we are then
required to look at the results and
confirm whether they are Portland or not
there are two main exercises in relation
to the national quality initiative
there's a main exercise that is run
every two years and we've submitted the
data sets in October the results of
which will be released in January
there's also an annual exercise which
matches the Electoral Register with
council tax information and the major
results are coming out of that is very
potent discount where person may applaud
any claim single person discount
explained in the solar business probably
but in reality is too
so that's the global you know actually
I'm taking on counterproductive theme
nobles will be available are thinking
generally mixture that's when we work
with beginning Council for next I'd like
to talk about internal audit
recommendations so if I can ask members
terms of eight point one two and one of
the things I could stay here as you
could progress as in month main since
the UM the last committee meeting in
July we've cleared a number thirty
recommendations I think this has been
prompted by the discussion of the
leadership team where we escalated the
lack of um implementation by service of
bombers so I think this discussion and
the subsequent email Brent brown for
service department especially now
prompted service departments to to begin
to implement recommendations as I stated
earlier there's there's we've
implemented a further 30 recommendations
so we feel making good progress in this
area
and yeah it's good to know that we
finally getting there on the recruitment
obvious being able to go for years at
least yes it is
I suppose my first question is really
only happy that we hang clear the
backlog and then get back on the track
all this think we now have two staff
which women to do the work in the first
place though the two people be cleared
of that look and then doing what they
were hoping normally to how long do you
think you'll be before we get back on
track makes to move in terms of clearing
the bankbook we refocused our efforts so
we will complete all the Priority One
borders to set out in the plan so we
won't deliver the plan that stepped up
and start the year all the orders as
identified project all be completed on
your end and will being able to provide
an opinion that feeds into the end of
government so basically we really looked
at the plans that we must deliver these
alerts so I can keep you assurance that
all the audits that for my opinion for
the end government statement will be
undertaken and we looked under thanks
something about fraud to audience okay
so we won't complete every audit that
was identified in the plan that's not a
team or less let me buy in resource and
that's been deemed
essentially we're complete all property
one and whatever we can approach to yes
and then there'll be an all known or big
plan which will be whatever just people
be at that point yeah we might decide to
say carry some of those audits we
identified in the a-team onion plan
forward yeah based on a risk assessment
if the risk is no longer there there's
been controls put your place we may not
look to our already plays area so we do
complete risk assessment every year so
those audits were in their plan for this
year we may say actually things have
changed a little bit yeah thank you the
next one is going to be a really silly
question what consider bank workers here
sure is quite fundamental to any of them
when I just couldn't cover a bit more
white it's quite basic and we seem to be
struggling with their voice though
what's the real problem with the bank
reconciliations we've got the detailed
form a procedure will be developed we're
all affected by different Bank a
miraculously Asia is in place by a new
range
we've never revised best I don't hate
writing now it's provides two three
first of all privacy okay to you
I'm sorry eight point two three oh sorry
government
yeah I mean I agree that it's before
focus on fancy finance activity to
ensure that we can reconcile I think the
the difficulty is partly arisen just due
to the number of sort of different
systems that we use part of the process
and the different ways that we received
money into the council so I think
there's some complexities around around
that and the timing issues specifically
in terms of when we get different areas
of money in I think partly it's also a
resource issue in terms of the frequency
in which we do that I think we've
historically moved to doing the
reconciliation that's frequently and
then it's obviously a more time
consuming process to do it when it has
to be done so I think going forward
we're looking to increase regularity of
the eyes so that it doesn't become such
a sort of arduous process to then
reconcile we start them but I agree it's
an area of concern and we are still
focusing on that and we once have a
robust and procedure obviously in place
to ensure that that's the case I'm sorry
this is the age of refer to the physical
bank account level and your business
agreement but there are good procedures
in place every day to identify it on
expenditure
yeah we're quite happy with what's
coming in we look back this is time to
the vendor campesinos no problem but the
daily income expenditure is better yeah
but we just want to sort out where we're
at for some good knowledge at the bank
and cash right okay
so as I read this March 19 we would have
done a lot of work on it but not
necessary of solve the problem but we
may be a lot the way to author solving
your problem is that correct all
previously placed by the excellent yeah
that's the integer okay thank you I was
going on about all the dates but I think
there's been covered or there's such a
long a lot of them started 17
refinishing now only next see if I think
that's been covered well I did have one
other warm truck home right here is 8.30
letters second from bottom eight percent
system administration information rate
of rice will have animation creation
account in their own name with unique
password rather than a generic can logon
and in generic icons but will to be same
and subsequently and we've got
implemented as much as possible
can we just want some assurance that
this is not implemented as much as
possible
some give me a lot of comfort or a safe
but it could do if I understand it in
more detail because delete nobody call
that ever I think there's a couple of
historic ones that no one uses jump in
show from I get so it's a the way the
system is set up it has a couple of
historic system administrator accounts
which are used for back-end processing
and links to other systems interface
with client system because of the age of
the system the danger of deleting some
of those system admin accounts there's a
high risk of mine if we just delete it
what it might do to the backend so the
advice is time to leave them leave them
but they're locked down nobody can
actually get into them there's a size at
risk of just deleting him it might cause
some of those back-end processes to fall
over okay
to understand those who's not
unreasonable we do now keep a complete
list of all with a new straighten up
lawmakers now thank you
I think that was a big and turn of cash
receipts basically it's out in the
parking please the only main area where
is still taking yes it's in since the
removal of the automated kiosk at the
reception the only cash the authority
place is funny the majority of cash then
your third seat clicks is through car
parks we do still on occasion collect
cash court proceedings if somebody's
about to be committed to prison and they
have cash to pay their outstanding
council tax or business rates or
whatever it might be we will take cash
in that situation but apart from that we
do I just like to say I'm pleased to
hear that we will be on time because I
think dates the change slightly last
year and they
did that and lack of staff we've done
quite well to give kids just nudge me to
apply for that actually we do a
additional resource from Leon the
compliance manager he's over to thank
you a couple of words on my behalf as
well so on top of thank you joining us
people so every compliance manager who's
actually I was thinking one of them as
well so we have no additional resource
so actually it might may do more with I
mean stay and be happy here
do you know what you've got yourself
involved okay so this is item eight no
further questions
and proposal committee resolves the
update I believe in the 1819 audit plan
be noted the conclusions and results
that we need all the engagement see what
kinda system free be noted and the
updated status of audit recommendations
and explore we noted is that a brain
item no resume the council's corporate
risk management of registers is likely
each one is the update and training and
in addition risk 14 years have some
updates to the productive progress today
in addition to that we're currently
undertaking some work in terms of the
potential risks around practice and
there will be a report going into the
school council in December around that
we would also prevent and you will
details on that at the next opportunity
so and paragraph 5.1 note that we have
been doing some strategic reviews of our
overall framework document Hastings
wants to with one of our insurance sleep
spirit and then again the recommendation
easily launch it faster and excellency
meeting in addition to that I'm one of
our other insurance tablets have found
out some general awareness training and
simply focused on health and safety
contracts once
management with leadership team so page
9.8 we fail to respond to loitering
associate dean in the event of it means
no disaster well no there wasn't a
disaster party though the first one
would be impractical consequences lots
of internal public IT services which did
happen to us earlier this year which did
impact on us
the I know in hindsight easier to to
judge do you think doesn't mean
everything becomes a higher thing just
because something happened but aware of
that I'm concerned that we have the
quality of controls is down good but to
me they clearly failed am I wrong in
that
in what sense are they good or in what
sense does my percent of the returns
rating how does that link to the fact
that they're beautiful they might set
you might be right
obviously as a failure somewhere called
the controls because they would say that
the controls are one thing about and
we've got a place to respond to any
issue that arises so as we shall see
case an issue to arrive actually
materialized in terms of the IT systems
obviously not functioning but at that
point we have already presented a report
back to the Claudia which said how our
response to those so between we had
funds and control the price to deal with
out including sort business motive
response arrangements in terms of using
art of the message of methods of
communication etc so I accept the point
that we need to look at those controls
again in to make sure that they are all
robust but over the necessarily accept
this or predator the actual control
measures in place failed like said there
was a a loss of lighting functionality
which we have as I say reported back
separately to the relevant committees
and there Arthur there was further work
we are doing to make sure that those
controls are robust in the future so
yeah I think that's what I would
probably say that at this stage I think
that well that was of information from
the previous that was no yeah I think
for the purposes of this which you're
probably wouldn't want this place to
response to all of the detail in terms
of what actually caused the issue I
think that we sort of addressed the
causes and the response community I find
is in a network before and I think any
further work that's ongoing in terms of
audit recommendations and controls will
be heard out of the next six months
and fetched a report about this
Christian Jew course but I I don't
really want to forget to eat how about
will actually cause the issues because
the say I'm not the best place sort of
obviously to respond to that level of
detail at this meeting also from H I
think that this particular risk is
relating to Aniston I make your instant
disaster within the district itself not
say the council directly so where the
quality controls it does mention about
lots of insanity we also covered our
hours emergency response disasters and
emergencies as a whole for residents if
I just may come back on every pretty
garden absolutely great and that's what
I did say it does relate not
specifically tough loss of I to your
public high tech services because
mention that and it mentions out of
hours response arrangements and your
mentions IT restoration and cover
facilities I've written notes as well as
the emergency kind of business call
security plans all of which should
really like to having an up and running
IT system telephone system email system
very quickly which I think the quality
of controls says good are thinking show
that it may not have been good only if
that's going back to this quiz looking
after to monster to die so I think
that's been a little bit over luck in
terms of the timings of this report and
I just get nothing that you've said is
coming back which is what I wanted
because I think there's it probably
identified that there might be an issue
or a problem there which may not may
need looking at needs help there are
reports danger review committee as well
I mostly there and after that's been
established and we
the details of that perhaps we would
would be looking at controls again to
make sure that they are still remain
robust India yes so as part of the yeah
that report we will be looking at the
controls are in place and then the risk
register and and would be updated every
community to add any additional control
the out-of-hours service provided
through brentwood was through but you
know so it was through bazevich staff
through tendering tendrán
okay so I'm happy with that
so can we note the content of the
corporate risk baby stuff to him 2018-19
[Applause]
and I closed the meeting at 26 days
[Applause]